The answer is it doesn’t work very well. So the
reason for this is that anyone observing these
messages given that there is only a small
set while you can compute this value given the
public keys of C, B and A, you can compute the
value of Xi for the three possible votes, match
that up to the incoming votes, know exactly what
they are so there is no anonymity for the voters,
so either A or an eavesdropper could do this.
The second choice is a little more ambiguous.
See you could output any votes at once,
there is nothing that verifies the votes that C
outputs. But in this case because the encryption is
broken, someone looking at that votes that come in
knows what the votes are already and knows if C
cheats but there’s no point to the Mixnet if this is
what we do. So we need to do something different;
this by itself is not going to work. What we need
to do is add some randomization to our encryption.